ahora que sabemos un poco de fricción y
un poco sobre planos inclinados vamos a
combinarlos y calcular qué le ocurre a
un objeto en un plano inclinado donde
hay fricción resolvamos ese problema
tenemos una
pendiente de 30 gr que tiene fricción Y
tenemos encima un objeto que tiene una
masa de 10 kg y el coeficiente de
ficción entre este objeto y esta
superficie eh nos indican que es de
0.5 que resulta una hac una fricción
pues bastante grande Bueno vamos a ver
qué ocurre Cuáles son las fuerzas que
están actuando aquí ya habíamos visto
que una era la fuerza de gravedad que la
fuerza de gravedad va a estar actuando
hacia
abajo y Eh bueno como lo vimos esto lo
lo resolvimos en el problema del plano
inclinado para resolver este problema
tenemos que encontrar dos cosas eh el
componente de la fuerza de gravedad que
es paralelo a la
superficie y eh perdón el que es
perpendicular a la superficie lo vamos a
dibujar
aquí recordemos que la fuerza normal es
igual a esta fuerza perpendicular pero
va en la dirección hacia el bloque Esta
es la fuerza de la gravedad que es
perpendicular a la superficie y la
fuerza normal es la que va aquí hacia
arriba es la que evita que este objeto
caiga dentro de la pendiente y bueno
vamos primero a calcular la fuerza de
gravedad la fuerza de
gravedad tenemos que bueno eh habíamos
puesto que la aceleración de la gravedad
era aproximadamente igual a 10 m por
segundo al cuadrado por la masa que es
de 10 kg 10 * 10 es igual a 100
New la fuerza perpendicular al plano
inclinado y que tiene dirección opuesta
a la
normal bueno en el video del plano
inclinado eh vimos que el ángulo que
tiene este plano va a ser el mismo
ángulo que hay entre este vector de la
fuerza de gravedad y este fuerza este
vector de fuerza perpendicular Eh bueno
Eh entonces el
ángulo entre de aquí también va a ser 30
gr en ese video vimos la demostración de
cómo eh Por qué este ángulo podemos
decir que es igual a este ángulo si
tienen dudas Les recomiendo que por
favor revisen ese video para que vean la
demostración Bueno vamos a dibujar
también el vector fuerza que es paralelo
a la superficie Para que vean que esto
es un triángulo
rectángulo el vector que es paralelo a
la superficie va más o menos por
acá y esto es un ángulo recto Este es un
triángulo rectángulo
Cuál será la fuerza perpendicular Bueno
vamos a recordar nuestras funciones
trigonométricas que no hace daño que las
escribamos de vez en cuando que son seno
coseno y
tangente y aquella función
trigonométrica que nos relaciona el
cateto adyacente y la hipotenusa es
nuestra función
coseno
Entonces tenemos que el
coseno de 30 gr va a ser igual a Bueno
podemos decir la fuerza normal hablando
en cuanto a magnitud porque recordamos
que la fuerza normal va hacia
arriba pero la magnitud de esta y esta
es la misma solo cambia la dirección
entonces vamos a trabajar solo con la
magnitud de la fuerza normal
entre la fuerza de
gravedad y lo que queremos
saber
es Nuestra fuerza normal vamos a
despejarla la fuerza normal bueno la
magnitud de esta fuerza es igual a
Nuestra fuerza de gravedad por el coseno
de 30 gr en la fuerza de gravedad
calculamos que son 100 N y se acuerdan
si se acuerdan el coseno de 30 gr es
igual a la raíz de
3 entre 2 entonces es 100 N por raí 3
entre 2 100 / 2 es igual a 50 por
ra3 New Y esta es la magnitud de la
fuerza normal que es lo mismo que la
fuerza eh perpendicular al plano Solo
que va en sentido opuesto bu quizás los
estoy confundiendo un poco porque estoy
repitiendo lo mismo pero es importante
que siempre tengan en mente la
diferencia entre estos dos
vectores Okay eso es lo que encontramos
en el primer video Ah no perdón Perdón
Todavía nos falta tenemos Entonces
quiero calcular ahora mi fuerza paralela
Eh mi fuerza
paralela es el cateto opuesto sobre la
hipotenusa entonces voy a utilizar la
función seno de la misma manera tengo
que el seno de 30 gr es igual a mi
fuerza
paralela
entre mi fuerza de
gravedad Quiero conocer la fuerza
paralela entonces la despejo paso de
esto de dividir a multiplicar entonces
me queda que es igual a la fuerza de
gravedad por el seno de 30 gr y quedamos
que el seno de 30 gr es igual a 1/2
entonces la fuerza de gravedad es igual
a 100 New por 1/2 que es igual a 50 n
Nuestra fuerza paralela qué es lo que
encontramos Ahora sí en el video
anterior cuando resolvimos para un plano
inclinado sin embargo ahorita estamos
trabajando o vamos a incluir la fricción
por lo que esto eh Bueno eh eh Cuando no
tenemos fricción esta fuerza encontramos
que su aceleración era de 5 m sobre
segundo cuadrado Entonces ahora tenemos
que ver eh Cómo usar la fricción para
calcular la aceleración y recordamos en
el módulo de fricción aprendimos que la
fricción siempre va a actuar en el
sentido opuesto de donde estoy aplicando
la fuerza si este bloque se está
moviendo en esta
dirección Bueno mi
fricción vamos a ponerla en otro color
que se distinga la fuerza de fricción va
a estar operando en este sentido fuerza
de
fricción entonces Eh bueno recordamos
también que la fuerza de fricción es
proporcional a la fuerza normal o a la
fuerza perpendicular a la superficie que
en este caso es 50 por raíz de 3
New así que bueno vamos a poner los
valores esta fuerza
eh perpendicular a la normal es igual la
50 por raí 3
New ya que calculamos la fuerza de
gravedad de 100 New y la fuerza
paralela esta
fuerza paralela es igual a 50 New así
que tenemos todos estos
valores Bueno calculamos ya tenemos el
dato del el coeficiente de fricción y
Nuestra fuerza de
fricción aplicamos la fórmula de fuerza
es igual a masa por aceleración entonces
la fuerza de fricción es igual a la Ah
No aquí no la aplicamos al contrario
aquí aplicamos el cálculo de la fricción
es igual a la fuerza
normal por el coeficiente de fricción la
fuerza normal encontramos que era 50 por
ra3 por
0.5 y bueno Cuál será este
pun 5 por 50
permítelo listo mil disculpas por esta
interrupción Bueno entonces estábamos
calculando esto
de 50 por pun 05 es igual
a 25 por ra 3 New Y ahora cuál va a ser
la fuerza neta O la fuerza total en este
objeto bueno tenemos entonces la fuerza
neta
va a ser igual a la suma de todas las
fuerzas involucradas al menos en estos
sentidos tenemos que la fuerza de
movimiento o la fuerza que queremos
conocer es este la fuerza neta que va
hacia
acá es igual a la suma
de la eh lo la fuerza con la que estoy
empujando que es esta fuerza paralela
que encontramos que es 50 n hacia
abajo o bueno hacia esta dirección del
plano inclinado y la fuerza de fricción
va en sentido opuesto Entonces la voy a
restar y la fuerza de fricción quedamos
que es -25 por
ra3
New Y bueno ya hice unos cálculos
previos con la calculadora si no me
creen les invito a que hagan esta
operación Para que vean que el resultado
de todo esto es igual a
6.7
New
entonces bueno la fuerza neta que sigue
siendo bueno es positiva sigue yendo en
este
sentido la fuerza
neta es igual a 6.7 New y cuál va a ser
la
aceleración despejamos la aceleración de
nuestra fórmula fuerza igual a masa por
aceleración en este caso es la fuerza
neta
por la Quiero saber cuál es la
aceleración
neta despejamos
aceleración es igual a la fuerza en este
caso la fuerza neta entre la masa y es
igual a
6.7 10 que es igual a
0.67 m por segundo cuadrado esto es
fascinante hace dos videos resolvimos
este problema sin involucrar la fricción
y vimos que el objeto se aceleraba a 5 m
por segundo al cuadrado que es bastante
rápido pero cuando incluimos fricción eh
Y bueno vemos que este coeficiente
indica que es una fricción bastante
grande eh vemos que el objeto se hace
mucho más lento es su movimiento de
manera que solo se acelera punto 67 m
por segundo al cuadrado Aunque no es una
aceleración del todo malao pero que es
mucho más lenta que cuando no tenemos
fricción incluso podemos calcular Cuál
será el coeficiente de fricción
necesario para que el objeto no se mueva
ustedes lo han experimentado cuando se
paran en una elevación y sus zapatos no
se
resbalan esto es porque el coeficiente
de ficción Es mayor que la fuerza de
gravedad que es paralela a la superficie
y es por eso que no se resbalan hacia
abajo en una pendiente pero esto no lo
veremos en otros vos hasta
luego